we all have fear you to be truth we all
have fear it's just how you deal with
it and um you know Einstein said you
imagination is more important than
knowledge but knowledge empowers
imagination and what most people lack is
real business knowledge like accounting
you know like debt like taxes you got to
know that stuff but they don't teach it
in school to anybody first of all let's
go back to what is financial educ ation
it's not get a job work hard save money
and invest in a well Diversified
portfolio stocks funds mutual funds and
ETFs that's not it you know money
is the financial industry is two things
debt and taxes